hello hello hi what's your name uh james
james lovely james and what do you do
i'm a civil servant a civil servant
lovely in london here uh yes in london
are you from the london area uh no i
live in london but i'm originally from
um suffolk
oh oh yeah it's a suffolk massive
yeah is he mentioned in the song
probably yeah what school did you go to
um
so i went to brandeston that was sweet
yeah
i went to primary school oh okay did we
know each other yeah
i'm not wearing my glasses james hello
yeah
james yes me that's the one what the
[ __ ]
do you do that was my best mate growing
up you're kidding me
and now you're talking to him on a
monastery i'm not having respects and
he's like
oh my god can we not flip him and just
get him out of here
do you have a story or do you well yeah
i did but please let it be about edge
it's about it okay okay tell your story
then we'll flip you and then
i'll sit with you okay okay cool so um
yeah this is so random mate yeah
it's really weird um yeah when we were
younger ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates
um and i remember one time um one time
he was coming around for tea
um and i've forgotten to tell mum he was
a vegetarian
um at that point anyway and um so mum
cooked
i think the sausage and mash for tea um
and ed said you know after the meal
these are the best sausages i've ever
tasted you know where did you get them
from
a mum had to lie because she had no clue
um
the first time i ever watched the
simpsons episode was around your house
as well yeah that's right
okay well done we're gonna flip you now
and then uh we can be reunited backstage
okay
[Applause]
surprise surprise
[Applause]
one of the things you can do is you can
conjure up uh people's fears
yes okay yes so you you're afraid of
quite basic things
i'm afraid of like most things like
anything high risk i'm terrified of but
those are rational things okay
irrational is
like spiders cause but they actually um
i
become paralyzed when i when i have a
spider in my room really
yeah i like wish i were tougher than
that but
i'm not okay now walker flow were you
serious when you told us what your fear
is
i mean it is it's a good fear it's i
think it's a founded fear
i think it's a founded fear it is tell
us what it is um
i have a phobia of being chased around
with poop on a stick
that's fair yeah i wouldn't say i'd say
we've all got that fear
there's another one that goes up for
that
it started when i was a kid
it was just weird parenting for some
reason
kids thought it was funny to stick a
stick and dog poop and chase each other
around with it
but that scared the crap out of me
because of the cleanliness problem of it
no spreading germs
this is afraid of sticks
but now jeremy renner though yours is
brilliantly specific and i think without
knowing it i think we probably all share
it
we we may i don't know i i didn't have
the the fear when i was younger because
we've all
we all go through this but it's when uh
a little child and i'm i'm the oldest of
seven kids and i got a lot of little
rugrats running around
and they these little roaches start
losing their teeth and they get a little
wiggly and they like to show me like
this little dagger
flipping in and out of their mouth and
like look at the jeremy i want to pull
this thing out i'm like
get out of here you're freaking me out
but don't you think that is really
freaky
it's like her thumb it's just weird
again
it just really kind of grosses me out
the cutest little thing on the planet
starts to do like the creepiest thing on
the planet and i'm like get out of here
like here tied the string to my thing to
the doorknob i'm like get out of here
creep
disgusting
that's now no little ones running around
flipping their little fake
teeth falling out look we all have this
you know when you're you have the dreams
your teeth full out i don't know what it
means anybody know what it means
we get bigger ones no
you have bad dreams am i the only one
that is
maybe i'm just afraid of my teeth
[ __ ] falling out
[Applause]
sorry now josh let me look at your what
are you afraid of
well i was going to go with flying but i
think i'll go with
girls over 12.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
come
[Laughter]
the last minute of my life i wouldn't
have predicted that
that was it mark ruffalo you're not
going to believe what he said to me
he was bang on the money
don't try and justify it
do you know what i've always hated the
hulk he's [ __ ]
my son said that to me the other day
when he was mad at me
what that you wouldn't like coming here
i always hated the hulk i think he's
[ __ ]
and you just told him that he was afraid
of girls over 12.
for him that would be okay he's a child
uh you were starting off in wrestling
you had a persona
that am i right it was sort of half man
half machine was that
correct yes this was prototype it was
awful
yeah so you uh you want to try to find a
persona or here's some more inside
baseball for a gimmick
where is it describes you as a character
so like when you walk out people
notice you and they kind of you can
describe your character
but these are not gimmicks these this is
real well whoa
i mean if they work it's yes but you
kind of it's it's a
trial and error process with a lot of
errors and uh and my first try was
uh the prototype which was half man and
half machine
and 100 crap but given that you're not
half a machine
how did you demonstrate you were a
machine well
i i used this ability to talk
rather monotone and would say things
authoritative and just when i said i
would kick your ass at the fairgrounds
on sunday i would rewind it and say it
again for you right
they say i would kick your ass at the
fairgrounds
that didn't work you
know oh it didn't that's a good one
anybody but but you worked on one i have
one
found huge yeah as john cena
imagine that i figure i need to come up
with some sort of name
yeah look everyone doesn't every every
wrestler has a name yes and people think
that like hey man how did you make up
the name john cena
i was like no dude i would have made up
like dick hammer bush or something cool
like that
no i'm not gonna dick or something i
don't know that's a star
no from there no one's letting you go
out with that
but uh they actually think that john
cena is a gimmick name but no that's
actually
through all the the presentation that is
wwe i'm stuck with john are you
wrestling around jamie
i used to love wrestling uh when we were
much younger about the same time as
transformers back in the day we had big
daddy
yep the giant haystack
[Applause]
uh no i used to love it i thought it was
just fantastic by the way i'm john cena
there's all these awesome names the
ultimate drooler
or like nothing and dressers like to
have uh
signature moves and things and one of
yours is the
you can't see me but that's correct is
that true that came out of your family
somehow yeah i was i was dared to do it
so
i was actually making the music for my
own theme song that you just so heard
and finally serenaded me to thank you
very much
uh and we played it for my brother and
the first time he heard it this was uh
the the 50 cent crew had a really
popular song called in the club
and he heard it the first time and
instead of dancing like he was our
litmus test to see what songs were good
what songs are bad
he did this oh my gosh
and i'm like dude what are you doing
it's like no everybody does this man
everybody does this
and i guess this was from 50 cents video
and he's like
you won't do it on tv so what the hell
do i got to lose am i going to fire me
of course i'll do it on tv
but instead of doing this i did this
and now for 15 years
because of a dare i've been doing this
and i'll do you one better people
actually think i'm invisible there would
be people
to look at this couch and be like why is
there nobody next to mcconaughey
john cena would be there but we can't
see him
so you never know do you remember
hacksaw jim douglas and king kong bundy
scandal bars and caravan eric's and
carry the claw
i got kicked out of here i'm talking
texas wrestling i get kicked out of her
see him in shreveport
for pelting scandal act bar with a bag
of tomatoes
on the 8th skandar akbar was a man
dressed as a sheik that used to throw
fire yes
and he managed king kong bundy who was
like 484 pounds
remember the missing parts unknown and
uh
the green face spit green mystic they
sound really good stuff
entertaining it was so much fun and i'm
john cena
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hi um hi what's your name my name
is sebastian
sebastian and where are you from i'm
from newcastle newcastle okay
do you live there or here uh i live in
newcastle yeah okay uh off you go with
the story sebastian
well many moons ago um i
actually went to school in newcastle um
and
there was a disco coming up uh there was
a really popular girl at school
um the usual side of scenario all the
you know all the guys after
um i sort of waited to the last moment
last couple of days
um and asked the girl one of this
popular girl question
if she'd like to go with me she said yes
this was literally
i think the day before the disco um lo
and behold
turns out that she was actually gonna go
with somebody else um
and that other person was actually
charlie sebastian olympia
that's the real man
could this have happened to two people
[Applause]
rachel gould but they're
very same yes you know who it is wow
you know at the time
and did you end up marrying rachel gould
uh no not yet no okay
there's still time no you don't happen
to have a sword with you do you
you could you could have revenge if you
want to do you want to
there you go
we thought we'd seen you play everything
but first which
mostly [ __ ] my first witch
but i hear you went through a phase of
you got offered a lot of witches
when i was 40 when i turned 40 i was
offered
three which is in one year
and it was sending me a signal i felt
about hollywood and how they felt about
people turning 40.
so i felt uh bad and i and it made me
sort of
i had like a little my backup you know
and so
no i didn't want to play them so a lot's
changed in the last five years for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it never works like that
[Music]